don't do well last episode was arduous
because of one of us I'm still stressed
out about it you made the call man I'm
just the juke master at this point Juke
master who got hit yeah but like twice
even the juiciest of juice stirs get hit
once in a while I thought I did have a
star's garden I think you're wrong you
don't have a box with me let me see I'm
a lockpick oh I got some disks some
hooks probably deposit those in the next
safe got a lockpick that's pretty
important I feel like that basically one
thing is what you need but that's like
our next move right yeah you're going
back out not the first fire you saw but
the one near the hydrant it's like the
east side of the alleyways now it'll
make where did he come from he's in the
police station right now I don't know
the lot he came from here so he's in
there he's in in the police station yeah
as opposed to the alleyways where you're
going thank God mm-hmm so I'm going out
this way yeah all right let's talk about
this for just a hot second I don't think
he'll be chasing you for a little bit
outside I have been wrong before
but you're wrong all the time you do
your best all right I'm going into the
alley but what door cuz there's a lot of
zombie out here well you gotta get out
or no go up press up or sorry sorry I
left or can you change the yeah you
should have your galley women up still I
thought I did but here we are um was
there a different button to change Maps
possibly probably at least get outside
and then check it he's I don't think
he's me chasing you outsider and see we
just well if he is and we can run with
it you can run literally jars
can you work in chores like this music
oh it's still wrong Matt I just go
through I remember where we're going
good kids I forget how to change maps
that's important sometimes it's not
about where you're going it's where you
end up it's where you where you begin I
thought was always about the journey
check the chicks for some items I've
been playing the game of life wrong this
whole time it is about the destination I
knew it
I don't you know there's a town in
Tennessee you called destination no it
seems like something you'd read on a
placemat at a restaurant it's also
something I made up probably is a town
all right enough banter let's go anyways
there's nothing I can do in here I
actually knew a girl named alleyway stop
I don't believe you I bet if you
Facebook search there would be a girl
named Anne no you're a lying
Sekhmet so I'm pretty positive going to
this door down here bottom right yeah
okay cuz you know the firehose or
anything to get you through that door
that's the only other door you right
right right right I need to get water to
get rid of that stuff just keep going
straight down the alley and oh there's
so many Psalms and this these cars by
the way like blown-up cars because I
know like saw someone saying like a lot
of times these burnt-out cars have items
yeah we haven't done a very good job I
think of finding secrets like you found
me a few what it's about the way a
secret word do that you can hear those
SIDS yeah check that car
yeah anyway this hydrant it's broken
books why does she have water in her
boots do you hear that did you hear that
puddle wow she might have a little bit
of water in her boots okay electric
boots little lyric
[Music]
I feel like I'm thinking about a
different kind of yeah you're going down
here I was thinking the one with the
jets I was doing the one where he's like
when I read it comes along you must whip
it is that a song that's a song it's a
very good song
can I get hurt if I go here I was just
looking for items that's all
dank Banksy grows litter in this yeah be
there everywhere wait
come at me god I love her shoot position
you want some fat oh you went with of
this it's not even like the utility of
tying your sweater like that it's just
so like lazily oh I don't I'm not warm
right now I have a warm fire in a fuel
drum keeping me it's alright there's
probably a crowd of zombies coming at
you or something big oh I see I see
now let me prep for it in advance for
this I basically want to get not that
far it'll just it should attract your
gun I want to get here there's a button
for it [ __ ] you hold LR 1 and then press
l1 to rotate target's I think could be
wrong but it should like I think it was
our one was items and our two was
everything else okay but I can't
remember I'm also gonna just make sure
that how many bullets I can have in
there nope good call Mary smart smart
girl alright um do you think he'll move
when I touch him when I walk past him no
he's pretty part of the
oh my [ __ ] god I saw that it was
alright a licker [ __ ] should I changed
with shotgun or do you think I can get
him in the in the boiled in the barrel
drum I would rely on the drum knees it's
not just a place in France it's not just
a connector on your leg oh dear diary
following six months of intensive
training my body's edges returned I'm
finding new places I never thought
existed before I was good soldier but
they ordered my execution with no reason
given I was tortured and forced to give
a false confession but the morning of my
execution a miracle happened
the company had helped me out giving me
a second lease on life dear diary I
ended my vacation he's on vacation right
after he got out of this life what else
would you do when you were almost dead I
would go on vacation to already go to
eat eat nice just drinking my alright
whatever and return to the HQ office it
looks like my hu BCE s units been called
into action I wanted to say it really
fast but I got confused
umbrella maintains its own paramilitary
unit to counter corporate terrorism and
VIP abduction it's complicated in
addition they have night men who
specialize in handling problems caused
by illegal products I am currently a
member of the latter now you're going up
against the night man Donald but we're
not the Dayman but we are still slogging
through this nightmare there's no
provisions of any kind the undead walk
the streets feeding upon the flesh of
the living all right we're getting here
Death Row's a heavily siloam compared to
this fellow he would have preferred to
die
oh I've chosen to kill myself damn such
a detailed suicide note it's really good
Laura though remember the intro and it
showed a bunch of people fighting
zombies there's a bunch of umbrella
dudes with umbrella logos in there yes
[ __ ] you was that hiccup no where is it
probably getting a firehose right now
you'll be back is it in the place I'm
not in it's just misleading all right
where am I
there's a dead end to my right my
character's right camera background
right now okay let's check that out
first oh my god just like change camera
angles for God's sakes there's a fire
hydrant fire hose is fixed with bolts I
need like a wrench or something there's
like nothing good about this it's been
too silent for too long yeah like if
nothing else should I take these you
want to look at my inventory sure you
can I think you can combine all three
herbs in this game like red blue and
green oh really
I could be wrong and you might be like
wasting space if you try and it doesn't
work sorry I really don't have a lot of
space because I have those pucks so I'm
thinking no and I can come back for them
okay if this looks like a safe area
which I'm stoked about safe what what
indicates safety here for you we'll go
through we'll find out there's no noises
there I can hear some SIDS right now
Rose have never been a good thing in
resin evil yeah I guess there's like
nothing comfortable about anything ever
oh so you hear that music that music is
like danger to me mm-hmm what am i doing
I don't know if that was music I think
that was like that's music and gun go
check it out let's go check it out yeah
that's like a machine gun
I hear ya sighs uh turn turn turn
[ __ ] you wait a snap and I need to look
it up cuz I got this deaf blend of like
dog killing going on whoa Jilly's gotta
again suck leg k9 dick
k9 dick alright no girls no I hear dudes
eating somebody say I hear it too super
safe area
well I'm safe tour bus I love cars I was
muted I never said I never heard that it
seems like a safer the other one the
alley
the one with it you can cover your
tracks all you want
people have watching this video can
rewind right now and I was referring to
the alley with the blue herbes nothing
especially strange here
come on that bus drivers in his totally
in his seat but not jacked up on two
cards wait a second he doesn't have a
seat belt on um there's definitely dudes
eating a body right I agree suck it suck
it
Oh suck it you can growl all you wanna
kill you hurry up and die I got stuff to
do today my clothes are getting out of
style that bus was made for that
specific route there's no like Digital
Reader on it I can't change routes
that's the 33 Midtown that's correct um
I'd like to understand where I'm at
there's gonna be dudes to your left but
there will be items as well okay well
I'm just saying this so they're worth
killing I don't hear the noise anymore
so I'm gonna swim in they stop and
they're walking this way right now Shh
oh he's oh I was a dog eating him check
his body does a wrecked car blocking the
way he's alive no he doesn't just die
nice oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
when do you when are you like a totally
new grenades right now because I always
think I would prefer shotgun shells like
always yeah I don't know I just can't
imagine a time or I want to Grenada
unless it's like a specific boss and I
need to like put one in a tunnel
somewhere do you know I mean yeah like I
would always that's the whole thing
about this game I don't really know all
right that's it here we go screeching
well-oiled door okay oh I heard stuff
okay okay one way up here stuff what is
it what is it
oh it's a dog so I wasn't even bothering
you I hope you know you wasted a bullet
shut up
yes how well you dodged I am
it's just r1 at the right time I don't
want to dodge you want to shoot them
stop I [ __ ] took damage for that [ __ ]
no I didn't
she's r1 or L anything but yeah it's no
it's automatic I didn't do anything
I was holding our one down to kill them
I don't think that's true dude it just
happened I think you pressed r1 and held
at the right time the proof is in the
pudding I hate that saying I hate food
sayings bit off more you could chew that
full plate Mike and I are like peas and
carrots Oh Rogers go see that the
sparking thing put your hands on it no
don't
it's not an option Mike you can't treat
me like I'm like Marv from home alone -
should I take this because then I can't
take anything else
sure do you know I wouldn't take it
actually see what else is around first
let's think what do you need right now
you need like something to cut bolts
with that's correct to put out that both
fires because I think there's items and
the one near by is that guy still
stalking me he's throughout the game
yeah but who knows where he is now
hmm it'll probably trigger once you get
the bolt cutter thing I would imagine I
bet you I need that power to get the
bolt cutters probably my guess it's like
a standard item exchange Puzzle Quest
god I hope this is a safe room with a
box because I could really use one and
now I want a million dollars
cool
I'm not going to quick there's ribbons
right in front of the timer okay okay
now don't save but no yeah I think I'm
doing really well like I don't think I
need you doing fine oh my god so jealous
wow that's a small they are so they're
like little they can't even make circles
that small with these graphics they look
like hockey pucks mm-hmm like a lot of
those you have nine now I only thought
they were huge
now their ink ribbons oh you use the
typewriter before I thought they were
like exactly like this they look like
watch batteries um should I make shotgun
shells or should I just hold on to all
that stuff go get that power
first I will there's also something here
I think it should can gun I get this
point there's no reason for me to make
handgun ammo so a is gonna sit there
unless I combine it with B but I like my
B because I like making shotgun shells
cuz it's just so valuable yours I'm
gonna take this why'd you say stars like
that cuz that's how that guy says it
take that you oh no it's a little flower
bud don't do that
there's gonna be something poisonous
lying around maybe was the liquor thing
when you go back you're gonna [ __ ] maybe
it did you try opening that door no I
will I was gonna take this then that's
pretty good thank you
it's very good Marvin president becomes
an actual skeleton that they made like
animatronic yeah did you ever see the GS
News I did where I we like mimic that No
oh yeah
which door you want me open this one
Tito it needs power which is why I need
the power cable right but where do you
activate the power in here in the save
room that you don't you there's never
objectives and save rooms I don't think
okay well then I have no idea what I'm
doing so go back and check no okay
there was another door in here don't
object if you're just gonna switch you
change your mind right after I can do
that so there's a door right here should
I try it
sure okay I've way more pucks now I feel
way better I was like down to like two
or something
Oh Oh I would reset that okay okay
I definitely got and definitely on that
might be worth shotgunning injured I'm
injured I'm on caution I would wait I
can take out two at a time with a
shotgun but if they come from three
different directions I'm still gonna be
in trouble so the shotgun will down them
I'd say fired a shotgun once or twice
and then get to a better spot where
she's in a corner with your back to a
wall it should be in the map now so now
I should have a view of what the [ __ ]
I'm doing I don't think it's gonna
matter I would say run to that corner if
possible afterwards I think wherever
thing is you mean this top part no left
oh so I can't stand you like they are
right now okay after I shoot them the
shotgun should make it lucky if they hit
me once I have to peel I'm gonna die
hopefully you have time man okay all
right all right okay okay and I'll have
my r1 equip sucking dodged okay here we
go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you Oh Dodge Stratus no
don't even heal don't even heal nice I
would piss nice what would you do I said
you said you want you would piss I was
gonna say pistol like handgun she said I
would piss I fit I meant like I would
pistol
I said pistol you'd be your pants yeah I
did do my pants so I could probably
equip my regular gun now income bin yeah
that was highlight reel that was really
lucky actually like I basically juked
into the corner that you told me to go
into that was not I mean it was
calculated but I I eventually want some
dedicated viewer with which I'm
appreciative to make like a highlight
reel not of your cool moments but the
moment you [ __ ] up no no do one of my
cool moments coolest we'll call it
coolest moments I'm gonna make it okay
cool I think that's it ghouls pet shop
patio patio no pet shop I don't know it
looked like patio hop now I think it's
pet shop no idea nothing special
yeah it's a pet shop was it bone hanging
but why would be you call it eagle I got
worms do you not get that reference
no I meant Dahmer oh I got worms it's
the name of the shop we're gonna open I
got
license to kill you have that power cord
on you right yes I yes I would like to
see the layout of the land
sons of [ __ ] there's probably dogs in
here I have a lockpick do that first
little injured I feel a little
vulnerable uh that looks like it's gonna
fall on my head can you shoot that
probably try it out no because I don't
want it to fall yet or do you think it's
gonna follow me if I don't shoot it I
was gonna say if there's [ __ ] coming in
here I could shoot it and then it would
fall on everybody's head yeah do you
think it's that kind of thing
sure yeah I mean they're not gonna do
like an automatic Dark Souls death I
hope I think yeah
[ __ ] Oh they've moved you out of the way
nice but yeah do that
oh my god I'm actually really got the
180-degree turn remember I don't feel
good about this at all
you can heal if it make you feel better
I would you think I can take one hit
right I could do a quick 180 turn and
then shoot him and then if you if it
doesn't like dropping or anyways play
your favorite okay okay okay oh I don't
feel good okay here we go
tip of tongue teeth and lips please so
heal yeah I just play your shock I know
I guess at this point unless you want to
run and still try to use the power I
don't know I mean it's not worth dying
over
yeah you got a bunch of beef I didn't
think was gonna jump over me I was
really unprepared for such an event
dang those liquors are souped up there
another one yeah with some music there
die sounds like it could probably use
the palate for the second one practice
the 180 degree turn right now but
yeah so you're gonna want to use that
once you come back here to shoot the
pallet alright you don't even have to
come back here and shoot the pallet just
a mop wherever you are it's like it
makes me like run backwards real fast
and I hate it
sorry I'm like I can't even do it
I'm like that scared right so I run
through here and I turn around and I
shut up shut up shut up I turn around
and I run and I shut up
okay I feel good I feel like I've
practiced simple one two three okay
now where's this bozo I don't know check
that bod probably add some gunpowder
again Oh that'd be great I'm powder beat
call me baby baby whoo you don't need
that unless you combine it with other
[ __ ] I'm gonna do I'll take it I do it
sweet
[Music]
sorry I just like gonna want to see the
lay of the land here should I go through
that door or should I go down the stairs
what do you think try stairs first I
don't think it's gonna do much but it
might be like a lockpick door Oh get
back to those pellets I've trained for
this sorry I think it would have been a
one hit kill go ahead use your shotgun
rounds roll with it
shoot yeah oh oh no mm LML oh shoot
shoot him a lot
turn around maybe and shoot him a lot he
keeps jumping over me yeah it sucks
oh I think you got that went so poorly
I'm sorry I suck okay that stick palette
I like first of all so I did the
turnaround but I accidentally pointed
down yeah and by the time I pointed up
he was like wait I thought he was gonna
like stand there for a second
I see a power line going there that's
probably the way to go for the door back
there I'm injured I'm like dissipate
wreck that door at the bottom just in
case it's not a lockpick door I doubt it
will be okay
I probably blocked another side I would
imagine it I'm really disappointed with
my well bounce back no it's up okay
elevator imagine the power would help
with this sorry okay so okay maybe the
batteries behind the firehose door [ __ ]
I'm actually still disappointed check it
off well I don't have any health now
like if I get hit I'm in a lot of
[ __ ] trouble yeah so like I gotta
check I can always turn around but if
it's dogs I got a lot of angry I got no
shotguns well you don't need shotgun for
dogs they all unless they're surrounding
you but yeah you should be good here
right then oh god a restaurant I feel
like that's gonna be a cutscene but
there is save room oh not too far from
here I look the newspaper office okay
there's a safe room right here I mean
that yeah I don't know if there's a box
in there it's a safe room that's gonna
be at least nearby um so definitely I
would go that way go SoCo expect
resistance in this alleyway go here yeah
the restaurants aren't gonna be a
cutscene or do you think I should save
is that what you're suggesting I mean
it's not gonna hurt to go there at least
like deposit the Gunpowder all right so
go to the right you're saying I don't
think you're in shape for
Oh what is that coming from
I don't know come back and so I check it
out oh wait that's a dude on the ground
someone killed him but check it out
that's Azzam Oh herbs oh yeah but Basel
[ __ ] mm-hmm
I would pick those up you going your
nearest safe room okay okay and then if
I need one I can take one yeah I have
like I'm serious he's out just so like
if it says there's certain item you need
you sure sure sure okay
okay so we're looking for wisdom so
we're screwed game over
I'm sorry gotcha Oh your wisdom here
that looks like a but what are they
trying to say there's that your
knowledge your knowledge is in your but
there's gonna be knowledge future is in
our hands okay
nevermind so okay look wait sorry you go
back to our yeah I read that plaque okay
my Warren [ __ ] you all right go back to
where they just work sure click on the
vase in the middle that's not you looks
like that you can put something in there
no all right
it does look interactable though yeah
should I just look down here yeah
it's definitely be a cutscene I think
that was just learning he toured the
restaurant yeah it's gonna be I would
say go the safe room okay
there was a poster on the wall for
Resident Evil 4 did you see that yeah I
can't believe I [ __ ] up that scene
yeah alright so I just got a not die
yeah got it
[ __ ] how many are in here
it could be make sure you're like like
what if it's like 40 of them go forward
a little bit I know you could be wasting
a [ __ ] ton of ammo [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it's gonna be worried yeah just
keep aim down it's better than I mean
even if you came from there might be
like a fuel barrel on the other side if
you went through the restaurant first or
something I have no dad
damn it not stay down dick there you go
okay someone else I hear them I just say
bolt for the saving room Ramsay Bolton
no I really can't take another hit just
take your time getting there
show yourself if possible and if you're
confident uh so many [ __ ] dudes
it's a reload right now or no did you
already my god back that sweet ass up
yeah should be low at least I'm like
almost not a [ __ ] bullet I wonder if
there was like fuel drum if you come
from the other side or something I don't
know can I be [ __ ] out he's a piece of
paper visual cue though
why the [ __ ] would they do that they
don't do that elsewhere that's true
alright just go save room okay cuz again
you want to go that restaurant
[Music]
okay take a left
got it here we go
okay hair time the save room isn't a
barbershop why give a [ __ ] where it is
okay wonder if I'd be a place to do a
shortish episode then make oh sweet so
there's a veil or something yeah I can't
take any more items but that's okay we
could I could call the episode there i
I've gone far enough where I want to
save so whether or not that means it's
the end of an episode or are we doing a
few ups in a row you don't necessarily
have to say oh no I mean yeah I would
say okay yeah we could do that we could
make this an episode and then keep going
cool we're not done yet so stick around
guys for more resident Knievel yeah